des élections qui n'ont pas été
organisée depuis 15 ans qui seront
certainement repoussé selon des
responsables égyptiens et sans nouvelle
date prévue le 22 mai prochain
les palestiniens devraient se rendre aux
urnes pour voter à leurs élections
législatives un scrutin fortement
compromis du fait d'un blocage avec
israël l'autorité palestinienne a prévu
pour cent cinquante mille électeurs de
jérusalem est onze bureaux de vote en
cisjordanie où aucune approbation
israélienne n'est nécessaire mais pour
les 6300 autorisé par les accords d'oslo
deux a voté dans des bureaux de vote
géré par israël l'état hébreu fait
barrage est interdit toute activité de
l'autorité palestinienne dans jérusalem
intra muros
mahmoud abbas a donc averti si les
autorités israéliennes n'autorise pas le
déroulement du scrutin dans la ville
sainte
l'ensemble du processus électoral devra
être repoussée nous n'accepteront en
aucun cas de tenir des élections
législatives sans jérusalem et ses
habitants le décret présidentiel devrait
être publié ce jeudi l'union européenne
ayant demandé aux dirigeants
palestiniens de laisser le temps à
bruxelles de tenter une médiation auprès
des autorités israéliennes pour bon
nombre de candidats
ce report équivaudrait à une annulation
des élections
un scénario qui remettrait en question
les droits et libertés des palestiniens
selon nous la tenue d'élections à
jérusalem fait partie de la bataille
pour la liberté de la palestine est donc
au lieu d'attendre à la permission ou la
coopération israélienne pour organiser
des élections dans des bureaux de vote
sous contrôle israélien
nous devons trouver d'autres solutions
on pourrait placer des urnes dans des
sites religieux dans des écoles il y a
beaucoup de possibilités que nous
étudions d'un point de vue juridique et
pratique et nous allons les présenter au
peuple palestinien quand les élections
devaient être organisées dans un climat
déjà tendu entre palestiniens et
israéliens pendant plusieurs jours de
nombreux heurts ont éclaté à
jérusalem-est
l'accès à la porte de damas lieu de
rassemblement
10 ionel des palestiniens pendant le
mois de ramadan a été dans un premier
temps interdit par les forces de l'ordre
israéliennes dans le même temps des
israéliens de l'ultra droite ont
manifesté dans le quartier
si la police les a empêchés d'aller au
contact des palestiniens elle a
également blessé plus d'une centaine de
ces derniers